hey everybody and welcome to a
liberating freeing wild ride with stevo
oh man we're talking about getting freed
from prison
and
free of shame and all kinds of other
stuff plus we're talking to
the
richest painter on the planet that's
right
this guy
painted the murals in the facebook
offices and they figured they'd just pay
him in stock
so he's now literally the richest
painter on earth
and he's a great guy and we had an
excellent time but before we get started
with that i want to tell you how i start
every single day i literally
meditate and then i want to drink my
coffee but first i know i gotta hydrate
and i want to do it in the most healthy
way so i got athletic greens i put a
scoop of this in my water and that's got
75 different vitamins all sourced from
completely whole foods
natural
it's like
literally got probiotics like every
little healthy thing and unlike
uh multivitamins not harsh on your
stomach man dump it in your water and
pound it down it's absolutely delicious
helps you stay focused it
improves your gut health and your
digestion
and uh man i just don't eat enough
greens so i'm telling you my ag one from
athletic greens it's what i am talking
about so that's how i start every single
day i think you should too
and if you go to athleticgreens.com
not only can you get all this great
stuff but with your first purchase you
get five of these free travel packs
which i don't go on tour without because
i literally do this every morning
and that makes it so easy
you also get a year's supply of vitamin
d from them
so dude
you can't do better i use this every
single morning you should too one more
time go to athleticgreens.com
stevo to get five
free travel packs your supply vitamin d
and you get all that with your first
purchase so get to it and let's get into
it
and uh we're ready to go
are we all going barefooted um is this
okay yeah
he's barefooted and i'm not this is the
first barefooted podcast
here yeah i'm always barefoot and people
complain about it like crazy yeah they
just can't see my feet he goes
barefooted into the plane in the
bathroom
yeah
and on that note
ladies and gentlemen david cho
yeah dude wow yeah dude to you bro you
just met scott randolph that's right
paul briskey what's up guys what's up
dave we are uh parked
in the rv give me the address a very
fancy neighborhood this is not the house
that you grew up in no absolutely not um
first question is has anyone dropped a
deuce in there
we went for a very long time with the
strict no pooping rule
and uh and then i just had to poop too
bad and i broke down and did it but i've
only pooped in there once
did you put a plastic bag in it before i
i guess i had done that before i had to
i guess i should ask has a guest ever
pooped in there oh a podcast guest has
now you have to poop not not right now
but it's it depends what we talk about
it could happen yeah you get nervous oh
my god if if we hit some certain
subjects it will yeah just flip my
houses right there so
i i like the idea
we could keep rolling yeah we'll keep
going with the door you can take it in
there yeah we can switch it out just
keep chatting you know pull that thing
right up on you too david all right well
there's certain subjects that make you
nervous
well i mean
yeah yeah
i think the more interesting question is
when you
feel nervous
that makes you poop
yeah i've had um i've always um you know
koreans can't for the most part
uh you know asians in general
didn't grow up with cheese
right dairy so
you know rice and you know kimchi and
all this other stuff but it's only until
uh you know asians started coming to
america
like
this is my understanding of it that the
first time you know so i think about my
dad my grandpa my great-grandfather my
generations of people that have never
tasted sour cream cheese pizza you know
like any of that [ __ ] and then so i'm
the first guy i'm the first guy out of
thousands of generations to ever
of course my shit's gonna like you know
i wake up i gotta take three to seven
shits a day i go see the doctor he's
like don't drink you know dairy don't
eat cheese all that stuff so i just go
i'm
i'm you know it's a lactose intolerance
yeah my girl is lactose intolerant but
is that the full story because you know
i'm like is that
is that normal for like someone to go to
the bathroom like seven times if you ask
my mom she's like oh yeah it's very
healthy it's a very healthy digestive
system yeah seven sounds like a lot that
sounds like a lot are they like healthy
shits or is it like diarrhea
no it's not healthy bro it's not healthy
it's
and uh so i sit there and i and i uh you
know i do the wikipedia thing or um
and i go what's what's um ibs like how
what's cause irritable bowel syndrome
what causes those things and they don't
have an answer and so i start reading
books about it and it's
like
most
like chronic pain is trauma like some
kind of traumatic thing or like yeah
stress induced and so i think about my
life today which is like
very very low stress
and then
this is this is a i'm grateful that i
can say this the blessing i can say this
the number one stress in my life is i
have to do a podcast once in a while
yeah and then when that happens i notice
i have to take a lot of more shits i
really like if i like i did rich roll
like a month ago i saw that ritual's a
good buddy of mine it's [ __ ] awesome
i love that but like i don't do like i
used to do a podcast every day and like
it was fine and i also [ __ ] like seven
times a day but yeah at my worst
when i was like
being competitive with like video games
and gambling and how many women i could
sleep with and all these things it was
just part of my curriculum i would just
wake up [ __ ]
[ __ ] like just everything is punctuated
with
bowel movement and now i had two very
healthy
healthy bowel movements today that's
good and um i try to do three
you try to [ __ ] three times a day yeah i
heard you i heard you should never push
never yeah you don't you don't wanna you
just it should just you know but you
never get nervous and have to [ __ ] like
scoring coke back in the day like you're
excited and you're like driving there
and you're farting and you got a [ __ ] i
mean the the first like bump of coke the
first line would make me [ __ ] like coke
has a very laxative quality but that had
nothing to do with nerves it had to do
with the actual drug
i i look at like
is that true because i heard
i heard um you know i'm not a drug
addict but i've talked to many drug
addicts and i knew a few
guys in rehab that were cokeheads and
they were like
we'd start to feel like we need the [ __ ]
before we did the coke
just just when we heard that like the
dealers coming and like the
ritualization of the the whole act of
their farting where am i gonna get the
money and it's like just
that part would get like oh [ __ ] and
then
and um
yeah so i'm just wondering if it's the
actual coke or the yeah i wouldn't be
surprised if there's a psychosomatic
piece to it but for my recollection it
was the immediate effect of the of the
actual drug um
but let me just say that you're uh you
know
this is the most stressful thing in your
life
like what an honor man thank you for
doing this no man sorry for stressing
yeah it's hard to put you through no man
i love it i love talking to fellow
koreans like uh i don't know if you've
ever heard this but steve oh is a very
typical korean name oh how about that
wow like oh like koreans have like five
last names lee kim cho you know um and
oh like oh h so
steve oh he's part of the tribe is
steven korean name oh yeah if if stevie
weeby stevie weeby for sure yeah when
you get when uh the koreans come over
here they're like what's like
bob joe jim steve eddie and then you
know throw tag on uh so
i think that you know americans being
being pretty ignorant like uh
is defined like the the the difference
between south korea and north korea
like i guess people probably pretty much
grasp it right that north korea is like
the crazy part
this is the way i look at it because my
my family's from south korea and
if you if
anyone's listening to this and they're
like oh i have a korean friend they're
probably from the south there's very few
like yeah like you got to do some like
like insane [ __ ] to get out of north
korea so um
most most koreans are from the south and
when people make that distinction it's
like it's an imaginary line right when
someone's like
then you could say say this about any
country but they're like oh you north
korean or south korean and i and i look
at at the world today
and
it's [ __ ] insane what happens in
north korea it's like it's insane what
happens over there and most people don't
really talk about or know know about it
because of the secrecy and i know
there's more stuff getting out
but
um like when people [ __ ] with me
and i'm in a like i said i'm in a very
great place in my life i'm the happiest
i've ever been but i've always been like
you sure you want to do that dude like
it's like right now it's 20 21.
and my people when i say my people i'm
just saying korea period north and south
still think communism is okay
like it's one of the final
final true communist countries in the
world that shows if you look at
countries as people
our level of stubbornness right the
whole world has like done all this and
that and like now we're even though all
of our people are dying even though all
like so that dna i think is like
imprinted
like somewhere in here because i've done
so many
uh and i've talked to you a lot about
this i've done so many self-destructive
does not make sense behaviors where
people go wait but if you just did this
or that your life would be easier and
i'm like i just and you know i'm better
about it now but
yeah basically i'm north korean
i wonder
i wonder if communism is really that bad
right i mean it's a philosophy communism
everything is communal we share right
it's [ __ ] dope if it were if everyone
if greed didn't exist
communism is great right you know it's
just in practice corruption will screw
up any form of government no matter what
it is and i think that when you're the
way that you said that they still think
communism is okay i almost think what
you're speaking about is dictatorship
right like because dictatorship and
communism are i'm i'm talking more just
about like the level of stubbornness
when
there's like
the reality of people starving in front
of you and dying and you're in there
just like
does not impute and i'm just going to
keep you know right and and
and actually the concept of communism i
i would guess the closest and i've
talked about this extensively but is is
prison right like everyone just get well
at least the prisoners right it's
supposed to be equal everyone there's no
special treatment and when i was in jail
in japan
japan is one place i have never been to
jail
i have been to jail in california
florida louisiana london england
stockholm sweden but hey life is a lot
better when you're not in jail at all
and life is also a lot better when
you're hydrated man and i'll tell you
for all the people out there drinking
soda it's awful for them
you know what's good drinking water man
and a nice cold sparkling liquid death
from the austrian alps
that's what i'm talking about getting
hydrated with nice
crispy liquid death man they also have
mountain still water and all of it comes
in infinitely recyclable cans that look
dope as hell
like
it just looks dope as hell and if little
kids drink them in school their teachers
think they're drinking a beer and i'll
tell you the ceo of liquid dead loves
that this is just a company that is
hilarious and cares about the world man
like they they donate 10 of all the
profits to
uh taking on the plastic industry death
to the plastic industry that's what
they're talking about they care about
the world and
they make my life better i'm a healthier
guy because of them and you're going to
be a healthier person because of them
too
by going to liquiddeth.como
you get free shipping on
any order of merch or
water
and dude that's crazy on their part man
shipping costs a lot especially heavy
water and they're gonna give you free
shipping jump on this man go to
liquiddeth.com
stevo you get free shipping on all your
merch and water orders
drinking cool ass infinitely recyclable
cans
and being a healthier person because
you're hydrated hurry up right now go to
liquiddeth.com
stevo start ordering now let's talk
about prison in japan
everyone gets one cigarette for everyone
gets the same meal
until they figure out oh this guy
if you're in jail and you have any skill
to alleviate the boredom right if you
can sing dance draw like anything like
tell jokes then you're so instant
celebrity
so once they decided once they realized
oh holy [ __ ] this guy can draw he can
like draw cards for us for our
girlfriends or our wives i was like the
celebrity and then i started getting
extra [ __ ] you know people were passing
me extra like
you know rice and like snacks and [ __ ]
and then
instantly when that happens it's no
longer communism right and then it
creates jealousy and like backstabbing
and like [ __ ] that dude and all that
stats and gambling right so in theory if
everyone could just share and everyone's
like equal like [ __ ] great you know
like
it's just
you know it works in topanga not in
different countries you know
how long were you in jail in china in
japan i was in jail for three months uh
serving a seven year sentence so they
let me out early do they serve you sushi
in jail i wish i wish bro
they served uh
like the most disgusting you know i love
it now because that's how drama works
yeah uh this thing in uh breakfast
called natto which is fermented it's
like smells like
kimchi it no it's
you throw it out all the korean [ __ ] uh
it smells like beans that someone nutted
on right it's like it's just it's just
it's a foul i thought it was torture i
was like liquid shrimp yeah
i'm like you guys are giving me like
rotten beans for i was like this is like
let me talk to someone from the u.s
embassy this is like harassment and
they're like oh no this is like
we all eat this [ __ ]
and uh yeah what year were you in uh
jail that was 20 years ago 20 years and
that's the last time i got got in
trouble
and that was the last time
um i was in shape
okay i just did push-ups all day i did
uh 1 000 push-ups a day wow 1 000. i
would and people are like no you didn't
and i go well yeah i didn't start doing
that month one i would do like i could
barely do 20 and then i was like holy
[ __ ] and then
um for people who are like that's
impossible or that's [ __ ]
wake up tomorrow at six is which when
you have to wake up in prison and then
have that be the only thing you date you
do that day till eight o'clock at night
yeah it's like you could do ten take a
break do ten have lunch clean your room
do twenty do thirty if you have the
entire day and that was the focus of my
day so when i got out i was i was pretty
ripped i was like that was the most i
was 27 20 yeah 27 years old
and then um
so wow so where are we the same age i'm
47. i'm 45. okay yeah so pretty close
and then i go on that [ __ ] rich roles
podcast and
you know part of the anxiety is like
like like um there's different stevos
right like there's like attic stevo
crazy out of control and then for me
the best
right now you're the best version of
stevo i've and and i love you and i love
hanging out with you thanks man likewise
so when i when i
and that's kind of where i'm at today
too and i think that's why we vibe
is like i notice people
who want
oh go back to that jail the guy that
would do anything like and i go i could
tell you a story about that but that's
not who i am today right and and my
co-dependents wants to please you so it
goes okay let me you know but
so i i i start to notice that those
people don't call me as much anymore
right because they're like oh you're
going to talk to me about some therapy
or some [ __ ]
and in the same way
the the
talking about [ __ ] and whatever the
the nervousness that comes up when i go
talk to a guy like rich roll is like
that guy used to be fat out of shape he
used to be an addict and now he's like
running 500 miles in three days or you
know i'm like
i i'm gonna naturally the kind of person
i am feel shame
just hanging out with him even though
even even if he's not saying to do
anything because i'm like wow he did it
he got his [ __ ] together like what the
[ __ ] wrong with me and um
so i did a show and he gave me his book
and everything and we talked about
recovery and and
i lost um
about 15 pounds
just from like [ __ ] just
just
yeah just like thinking about it
and then uh
and then i um
i i lost
you know my friend um
he like cooks for jeff bezos once in a
while right he's like a celebrity chef
guy
and he's mean he's mean to me so he goes
uh hey man every time i cook for basil
he looks like he's getting younger and
more healthful and he's doing all this
anti-aging [ __ ] and he's like you're
[ __ ] rich dude like you look like
[ __ ] fatter and uglier every time i see
you so he kind of shamed me and i and i
was like what
that is true like why why aren't i
taking care if i if i truly am the
happiest i've ever been why am i taking
care of myself better because when i
wasn't taking care of myself i didn't
give a [ __ ] if i lived or i died so i go
you know i go to the fancy hollywood
beverly hills doctors that are seeing
you know and i go yo bro i'm [ __ ]
rich like i want to live forever like
what do you got for me and they're like
there's all the stem cell [ __ ] there's
this there's that and i'm like all of it
yeah i want you know total addict
behavior i'm like give me everything
that's going to make me live biohacking
and they're like some of this [ __ ] you
got to go to korea some of it you got to
go to germany some of you got to go to
costa rica and i'm like i don't give a
[ __ ] i did stem cells in colombia oh
okay you got to tell me about that [ __ ]
wait recently or a while yeah like very
recently it was uh
it's a company called bio accelerator i
believe it's an american company but
they operate out of columbia because
it's illegal in america to perform the
procedures that they perform there right
and it's speculated that it's illegal in
america because the procedures they're
doing with stem cells there pose a
threat to the um
what do you call uh
pharma
like the big pharma and like and and
whatever like there's more money in
operating on people right of course
describing the drugs than actually like
getting to the root cause wait so how
recent was that [ __ ] when when was it i
just got a couple months ago or a month
ago a couple months i think you get that
[ __ ] too
no dude why do i look young as [ __ ] or
what no i'm just curious
yeah i want to go to the steve trump
like candidly they did it all for free
from me if i posted about it and it
worked out great because the the posting
that i did about it was like super well
received you know like uh that
everything performed really well what i
noticed though was that when i was
posting about being there there was just
a deluge of
like just people crying out desperate
for help with like chronic pain like
i have this like you know my spine like
i'm not pinned i'm in pain like i need
so many people i was overwhelmed with uh
just desperate cries for help and i it
just it messed me up so i talked the ceo
of the company into
doing a lottery to give away oh [ __ ]
royal treatment to three different
winners nice are they still doing the
lottery they they've i believe picked
one so far and they're just still yeah
wait so and initially they uh they
weren't they said that though the
treatment would be free but you have to
get yourself there and i
i piped up and said come on dude what
the [ __ ] is that you know yeah
i said i've got so many uh frequent
flyer miles accumulated oh let me cover
and travel for like two of the winners
you know and they're like and they said
cool we'll cover the third so so now
travel is all the third one has to
hitchhike oh wow
it's time suspenses kill me bro did it
work
exactly it's tough for me to
to say because
what i was there for
was uh degenerative disc disease in my
neck i can tell my neck's [ __ ] up but
i'm not in a like debilitated state and
i'm not in chronic pain so the idea of
getting stem cell treatment there was it
was largely preemptive
so i can't it's not like i have pain
that can go away so it's specific to
your to chronic pain right yeah they do
they do it different ways they injected
it directly into my neck into my
cervical spine and uh they they they
injected it like
[ __ ] tons of stem cells into my spinal
cavity the idea being that it goes up my
end of my brain stem and helps with
concussions and they also uh flushed a
[ __ ] ton through an iv so it just
circulates through your whole body and
and hones in on things that need help
uh oh and they injected a [ __ ] ton of
them into my face too which apparently
won't you look amazing make me look
younger well thanks dude and [ __ ] that
guy i think you look great
well i mean i also i've been work
working out you know yeah um and i also
think
that stress is more dangerous oh yeah i
think that like like like and trust me i
understand what it's like to be caught
in this like cycle of telling yourself
awful things about yourself right you
know all the negative self-thinking and
negative like like self-loathing that's
all more dangerous than like most any
lifestyle happening i would say well
look
i i i
i try my best every day to eliminate as
much stress as i can and you know
there's people like you said there's
crying out there in so much pain
and you know real pain like bone stuff
like actual but there's also a lot of
people out there you know in rehab my my
my um
my roommate was one of like the best
spine surgeons in america and he's like
he's like i'm you know i'm gonna big up
myself of course i'm the best and it
works i do it i people come in they cry
they change my life he goes in 100 of
the cases the pain comes back somewhere
else it comes back in you know so
somewhere else like you fix myself and
why is that is that like uh well this is
depends on you know
like i try to keep this kind of stuff to
myself but i'm here so i'll just talk
about it is
um
like it's like how open are you to
[Music]
like there's actually a lot of doctors
in rehab so
i get to i get to talk to them
we had the i was on your uh just the
show with the the your fx show and shout
out to it because i got so much great
feedback oh thanks man yeah i loved it i
loved it i appreciate it
on fx if you haven't seen it then
[ __ ] dial it up because it's epic
thanks when i was when i did my episode
with you i was getting ready to ride a
bicycle while having a
general anesthesia drugs administered to
me and when scott and i were were
figuring out how to make that happen we
spoke to a bunch of anesthesiologists
and they said stay the [ __ ] away from
propofol the michael jackson drug oh
yeah they said that that uh there's just
a straight epidemic of medical
professionals rampantly abusing it like
anybody who can get their hands on the
michael jackson [ __ ] is shooting
themselves oh yeah so i've met those
guys
and you know so these are people that
are medical professionals who abuse this
[ __ ] out of painkillers and propofol and
all these things ketamine is a big one
too man like
all the veterinarians are [ __ ] up on
ketamine right and if you talk to any
one of them they'll tell you
these you know they're like it doesn't
cure the problem
like it just numbs the pain it just
redirects pain and you're like literally
exactly the same your whole body so
you're not treating the the cause of it
you know so a lot of um
and this is the part where i lose a lot
of people there's uh you know when you
watch um
like uh like a lion almost kill like a
deer in the wild right like it's like
this close right it like almost kills
them and then the deer survives and like
three seconds later he's like at the
pond like chilling with his friends like
nothing happened so that's every animal
every animal almost survives dies every
day and they just go on with life and
they don't like they don't become drug
addicts or whatever
humans and dogs are the only animals
that some [ __ ] up [ __ ] happens to us
like like it happens to everybody and
then we carry it for the rest of our
lives in your brain yeah so there's
actually elephants
they say they don't forget they never
forget
you gotta break their spirit to train
them and i think he [ __ ] them up like
but then again i don't know yeah i mean
this is just what people tell me so i've
done all these like trauma release
exercises that like and you know like
old pain from like 20 years ago coming
out and so
um you know after talking to these pain
doctors and spine surgeons and whatever
because i have like
the [ __ ] thing the ibs going back to
the [ __ ] once again and all these
like chronic issues
um you know i started hearing about um
dr john sarno he wrote this book healing
back pain howard stern talks about him a
lot he passed away but that book oh i
remembered howard's turn talking about
john sarno yeah so it's about
you know and i'm nowhere near the person
that you know i just started doing it so
but i started like
talking to the pain you know because
like when i i realized
some [ __ ] was happening in my body the
ibs like it's okay let's just stick to
ibs because that's what i have it's like
[ __ ] there's the van
[ __ ] this is happening
there's a wild ride sign i'm about you
know it's like [ __ ] i hope i'm
interesting you know all these this you
know and then that manifests with you
gotta take a [ __ ] sure because if i
gotta take a [ __ ]
then i can hide in that room and i don't
have to yeah you know so is
what's going on there it's like social
anxiety the fear and then what's that
what does that link back to
so
um i threw my back out a few months ago
and i i was just like this is like some
old man [ __ ] i'm 45 i'm a middle-aged
man like you know i'm like i got access
to all this medical care i'm like i'm
gonna have to get surgery and i'm doing
all this stuff so i started reading this
guy's book
and you know i'm like you know i'll be
honest i didn't finish reading it
because i'm like just
that's how i read back and forth and uh
so i'm reading different chapters i'm
i'm
you know taking what i want leaving out
some [ __ ] and
um
i started talking to the pain i was like
what's going on like how come you you
know my you know people who know me are
coming into my room going like are you
talking to someone right now like you're
losing your mind and i'm literally
talking to the pain like hey it's like
it's cool man you don't have to do this
to me like you don't have to
and
i swear to god i know i'm going to sound
like a quack the pain left me
in like less than a day like it just
like i could walk i couldn't even it was
like that pinched kind of feeling where
every time i walk my legs felt you know
and i was like [ __ ] man i must have
moved wrong or picked up a box wrong or
something and it just left me and i've
been applying that because
if you believe like painkillers work
right you take a pill and it redirects
so you don't feel the pain so if a pill
could do that
there is a way if you do a lot of
meditation and mental stuff like you
could do that just without the pill
right it's a lot more work
so um
so
that's where
well i think one of the hardest things
for you and me both uh
to say is no right so i'm at the place
i'm like i got the money
all these jeff bezos dudes are doing
this [ __ ]
stevo did it right like i'm like give me
all that stem cell [ __ ] give it like put
it in my dick put in my [ __ ] like but
i put in places where i don't do it they
do put it in the dick oh yeah definitely
yeah
if i'm going to colombia put it
definitely put it in my dick you know
and so i sat there and i'm like filling
out the paperwork and he's telling me go
to the you know and i go
uh
it feels very addict-y right it feels
like i don't feel good instead of proper
nutrition and exercise why don't i just
like inject like i was i even asked him
i was like the pro phenol [ __ ] like just
knocks you out right like
i go
i go hey bro is there way
he's like are you really this lazy i go
can you just knock me out and then hook
me up to a machine that works me out
like while i sleep
and like when i wake up it's like bro i
got abs and like i'm like that's gotta
exist right here
it probably can't exist if you you know
if you have enough money you can pay for
anything but it probably
you'll probably end up the way michael
jackson did you know
and i wake up and i'm like oh [ __ ] i ran
500 miles you know
so i said no
and i walked out and i kind of went to
like victim sad guy mode i was like you
know what
just age the way you age you're a fat 45
year old
you're just
you're living that dad life that's who
you are just accept it
you you live in like the future where
they have grubhub and postmates and like
it's just it's awesome just like read
comic books at two in the morning and
like just have a cheeseburger like
you said that the only time you were
really in shape is 20 years ago so
presumably it's not like an age thing
right you've been this way for a while
so you've had shame for 20 years well i
mean part of it is money right like
resources like i
i've been like a skinny asian kid my
whole life until
i realized
my first paycheck where i was like i can
get a steak and the app
and the dessert and a drink you know
because i didn't grow up like that it
was just like yeah we didn't first of
all we didn't go out and if you did
you're not getting are you
is there like is it official you are the
wealthiest painter alive
i've heard it said that a good
interviewer will only ask questions to
which they already know the answer and
yeah he's the richest painter in the
world but we're about to find out how he
reacts to being asked that straight to
his face and while we're on the subject
let me tell you i'm not the richest guy
on jackass but boy am i trying to become
the richest guy on jackass and i think
i'm getting somewhere you know why
because my shipping business is really
taking off i actually just got my second
warehouse
for shipping all of our merch stuff and
man you know what made me so successful
in that business
yeah it's called ship station that's how
we make all of our orders go out super
smooth super easy and even more
importantly super cheap
because no matter how many different
platforms you're selling your goods from
shipstation takes all of those platforms
and funnels them into one super easy to
use interface and it gets you the lowest
possible rates on all the mail carriers
ups post office all that they're giving
you rates that are normally reserved for
fortune 500 companies and they're just
hooking it up now here's even crazier
and i can't believe they're doing this
at this time of year but for the
listeners of my podcast you get a free
60-day trial not even charged anything
you get to find out how great it is for
nothing if you go to
shipstation.com and when you get there
you click the microphone at the top of
the page and then that's when you plug
in the promo code stevo and that's going
to unlock a 60-day free trial now think
about when this is going down we're
about
we're about to hit the holidays over
here the next two months are the most
active
like e-commerce months of the year and
they're giving you this deal right now
crazy no matter if you're selling a
little bit if you're selling a lot like
ship station is your solution to getting
somewhere with e-commerce man and in
this day and age if you're not selling
stuff online you're blowing it so let's
start selling more stuff i know i
started selling more stuff now it's your
turn and do it well by going to
shipstation.com
using the promo code stevo again you hit
that little mic at the top of the page
and then plug in the promo code steve
well you're off and running for 60 days
for free no hassle shipping
man
come on
it's time to make ship happen
so yeah dude
get on over to shipstation.com and now
let's talk about money
um
yes
i got to ask my question then what what
was the first thing you did with your
first big paycheck
what would you buy steak and an
appetizer just a steak i mean you did
you well you're here
this this is this is the
the
it's it's not um
a sexy answer but i think
this is um
[Music]
must be nice
must be nice to be rich right it must be
nice to have your own sprinter van like
oh if i if i had you know all the haters
and like oh if i had your money i would
do you know and i and i go i do the same
[ __ ]
when i was poor you know like right it's
like
you you've done you get this right
you're like must be nice to be jackass
four in a multi-million and you're like
wait like i was doing stunts when i had
nothing with grocery carts
so
it's a weird thing to say to someone
like
i hitchhiked all over the world before i
had to dine i begged for rides i begged
to stay at people's houses i i was a
world traveler with no money right i've
paint i used to steal spray paint and
just paint like
food that i couldn't afford i would
shoplift so like i'm not i'm not you
know saying you should do this but i
just i did whatever i wanted right so
when the money hit the bank account
um not that it's not important it just
was like whatever you know and then i
did all the pitfalls i bought all the
cars i bought all the [ __ ] and i was
like
i don't need any of this stuff like my
life is very simple right like yeah and
uh it's like i don't have that much
stuff now like i'm trying to go more
minimal and almost all my resources and
time is to just like helping people and
and doing that but
um you know the the headlines is like
richest artists in the world and and to
be honest like when i met mark
zuckerberg and sean parker i didn't
believe in their company and you know
i've talked about all this stuff and i
wasn't on social media and i probably
still wouldn't be on i mean i'm on
social i have a social media presence
but it's not me like my social you know
i know this is all douchey [ __ ] my
social media team does that you know and
so
um
yeah i i was like facebook myspace i
don't like what i have friends like i
don't need this [ __ ] it seems so
stupid so
when facebook started taking over
myspace because you remember how
gigantic that was
i wasn't even paying attention
so like
like my whole life is gambling so i have
all these things that i would bet on and
some of them paid off and some of them
didn't and that was one that was paying
off but i wasn't even paying attention
to it
because my art career was taking off my
paintings were selling for like more
money than i you know but i wasn't like
as well known and the gambling was
taking off i mean i wasn't winning
i i figured i i kind of don't like
talking about it because
you don't want to encourage [ __ ] yeah i
don't yeah because it's it
um
people hit you up all the time about how
to be like stevo or jack at you know all
that kind of [ __ ] and it's
and it's
this is what i would say
because because my teacher caught me and
my art teacher caught me once giving
advice after i caught up and he's like
you know that advice you give is very
dangerous because you're giving it to
like normal people who aren't like you
and i think you and i
are i know this sounds very like
braggadocious but i think we're really
good
at making it look like we're just having
a good time and [ __ ] around and
making it look easy and just acting
stupid and crazy
and it doesn't account for the years
the years of discipline and all the
boring [ __ ] that we don't show right
like
like oh look at that guy's just throwing
paint i'm like bro do you know what i do
after the camera's off i just ch in like
the clown school you went to the stunt
like all this [ __ ] practice and then
when the camera's on you just do it
you're like oh he's just [ __ ] around
so
you know
yeah so people
it's it's more fun it's more fun for me
when i read the headlines even like it's
when i go watch the uh social network uh
movie by david fincher it's like it's
like i liked that it's [ __ ] awesome
but it's just not true every time
i was there for all of it i'm like wow
that is like the most
exaggerated like intense like hollywood
made up version and it was just not that
you know yeah sure this
it happens is there a documentary
version of it that that's actually
accurate
i'm trying to think maybe the
documentary version would be even more
crazy
every time i think about mark zuckerberg
i think about the actor that played him
yeah
and like and i'm friends with sean
parker and then when i think about hey
like justin john parker is the napster
guy yeah right justin timberlake yeah
you know the million dollars you know
what's cool a billion dollars
how about just
facebook not the facebook
yeah oh yeah you know what i i heard
something like from a few different
places just very recently that i just
absolutely loved and i couldn't believe
that i didn't like it didn't occur to me
sooner but the idea that
that money
doesn't change people it simply
amplifies
the way that they already are
um interesting this is something that i
first heard khabib
this is the fighter khabib nurmagomedov
he said it about conor mcgregor you know
like a lot of people want to give conor
mcgregor a pass because he just came
into like hundreds of millions of
dollars and it's going to make you he
said it could be something
like whatever you are money makes you
more of that and
what do you agree with that i do i do
and i've since heard that in uh in
multiple other contexts of that i can't
uh you know well i think that's true
like in the in the short time that i've
known you like you have money and you're
sending people to get help in colombia
like that's what you decide to do with
your money you know and
um
but then that goes to the question of
like who are we are we like are we evil
are we villains and
um are we good people are we here you
know
i guess
part of that is
um
hmm let me let me try like
like if i close my eyes right and i go
holy [ __ ]
i never need to move again i never need
to move again right like i'm talking
about a contraption that like i i can
hire enough people for the rest of my
life
where i i just don't have to do anything
i didn't have to walk to this van i
could have someone like carry me here
like
so if i think like that then it's like
holy [ __ ] you know
um then and then
like you don't know this [ __ ] this life
until you have it right so people are
like oh man you hang out with all these
rich people it's like
look there's these isms right more money
more problems with with uh money is
power with great power comes great
responsibility like these things are all
true for a reason you know and i i could
be like well i didn't want this
i didn't want this responsibility and
you know in that case i kind of sound
like spider-man like i didn't want this
it's like well you have it now right so
you have a responsibility that you
didn't want and now you got to do
something with it and so that's what i'm
doing that's
i i don't really
like talk about it that much um
like one of the things uh you know
five seven years ago was when i was like
the most out of my [ __ ] mind you know
and
and um part of getting better is
is service work right and and like i'm
like i'm not like i don't [ __ ] need
to lift a finger i'm not help you know
like oh you want me to help someone
here's a check and they're like
that's easy to write a check for you
like you got to do you got to like
put your effort and action you know
so
i'm like super into animals i'm super
into like dolphin therapy horse therapy
and like the first time i did horse
there have you done it you point there
god knows all about it my sponsor is
like the the
equine yeah yeah for equine therapy on
the east coast and west coast so all
right so like
the first time i did horse therapy i
don't know how to ride a horse so i'm
like oh cool i'm gonna ride a horse and
they're like oh no you don't even touch
the horse and i was like what what the
[ __ ] and they're like
um horse therapy is like
or the one i the ones i did was like how
do you get horse from a point a to point
b without touching it so then you see
all the addicts go go get over there or
like trying to bribe him with the apple
and it's like it's just like when you
calm down
the horse mirrors you right so when you
calm down the horse calms down
so
and then it follows you so i'm
i'm like all right cool like that's i
want to do something with that so i was
living in arizona a few years ago and
i volunteered at this ranch who does
equine therapy with um
at-risk youth uh like kids with autism
and just special needs and addicts and
i'm like dude i'm gonna become like this
horse and they go
um we don't need any
we need tons of volunteers but we have
enough of those people we need people to
shovel [ __ ]
and in my mind cause you know i'm like
dude i'm [ __ ] dave joe like you know
how much
like i'll [ __ ] hire a team of people
to shovel you know
let's my ego flaring up right i'm like
i'm not [ __ ] shoving [ __ ] and then my
sponsor at the time's like bro we're
shoveling [ __ ] that's what you're doing
and my ego is just like out of control
it's like i am 100
how is this gonna help me get better
it's like you don't know what you don't
know until you try it right
so i shoveled [ __ ] for almost a year
i went there every day complaining like
you know and i went under there for like
a different name because i didn't want
anyone to like google me and you know
and i'm just like watching kids and like
in my mind i'm like i love [ __ ]
teaching kids i love like helping people
like i want to do
that [ __ ] over there and they're like
yeah so there's more manure here and you
know and and you know that kind of [ __ ]
when you do you smell like it all day
even if you shower right so i'm smelling
like [ __ ]
but during during break time like i'm
doodling like and so one day the the
lady that owns the whole ranch is like
um hey johnny
hey johnny i you you're like really good
at drawing and i was like oh thanks
and and she goes you know we're having
um
you know we're having a special event
this weekend for like victims of abuse
like do you want to do you want to come
and draw portraits of them and i was
like yeah sure like and then once again
the ego's like
[ __ ] do you know do you know how
much i charge for this [ __ ] like what
you're getting right what do you think
i'm
working at magic mountain like one of my
[ __ ] clowns
you know character and i and i go
yes i'll yes i'll do that you know
so i get there that weekend it's like a
special day and it's like all these
services for like you know these people
that have been abused
it's like free hair free manicure like
free clothes like all these people
setting up and so i sit down with like
my little easel and it was all
sexually trafficked you know
the victims of like ex-prostitutes ex
you know
and um you know
i had been with
i don't know how many prostitutes in my
life you know all over the world
and
i just i i just froze up
had to take a [ __ ]
kind of just hit in the bathroom and i
was like i should just go home like i
just felt
i just felt shame i was just like man
i've i've been a part of this and this
is not
this
i can't i can't heavy i can't be here
you know and as i start to walk out the
door
uh the lady's like hey johnny you know
first the first woman you know she's
ready and she's like
so uncomfortable because she's like no
one's ever
i've only been looked at as like a
sexual
being i've just been used by men and i'm
like oh [ __ ] dude
so i sit there
and i start drawing her and i'm like
i gotta [ __ ] like i gotta make this
like the best drawing i've ever done in
my life
um so
so i'm like and i'm a little rusty
because i've been doing the shoveling
[ __ ] you know
so i'm like drawing her and i'm trying
to make her as beautiful and i'm like
and i'm like really seeing her and then
she starts crying because she's like
i've never had anyone draw my portrait
in like
jesus so
she goes and she goes takes it to all
the other women there and she's like
this guy over there just drew that so
then the line starts forming
and i'm like holy [ __ ] like this is
crazy and there was like 50 women there
that day
and all of them have like the most
heartbreaking you know
the worst stories ever
and you know i the event started at noon
or something and they're they were only
going to go till five and i stayed till
midnight and i drew all of them and like
everyone went home and i was still there
and um
it just like broke me you know just like
destroyed me and
um there's a part of my ego that's like
hey guys you know i'm famous you could
sell this thing and
you know but it was just
it was so
raw and so personal and
and i go
anyone could write a check which i do
that also right
and i tend to do that anonymously i
don't like being hey the dave cho part
of this you know i just do that but i'm
like
i'm i have a skill i can give back like
i can help people so like i that's
that's where i that's that's how i spend
my time i stopped selling my art in 2009
so that's all i do now i do murals i do
anything where my art can be seen or
received for free online murals posters
whatever i just give away or doing
murals with kids or people that have
been like you know that's that's my work
and
um when you did the drawings of all
these 50 women you say it broke you
but
the way that you told that story is so
beautiful it
seems to me that that would have been on
some level healing oh i mean
it it broke me and it and it healed me
you know it just like i i think i just
like cried the entire drive home that
day and then i just uh
i just yeah just the whole thing of
addicts don't care about other people
addicts don't give a [ __ ] about
um and just to clarify anyone listening
and it's not a competition i'm not a
drug addict i'm not a i'm not a um
alcoholic i'm a sex addict a gambling
addict
recovering
food addict alcoho you know workaholic
all the process addictions you know
shopping
sex food love
all those things and like the the final
ones that i'm struggling with
are
food
and
me too right like i mean when i met
stevo this is my first conversation he
comes into my house i'm you know the
koreatown house and i'm and i'm painting
him for the show and he's like bro i'm
skyjacking he's like he's like i don't i
don't he's like he's like explaining to
me i don't ever watch porn again i don't
watch porn anymore i'm like
tell me how you did it and then in the
next breath he goes so i'm watching porn
as i'm jerking out off out and i go wait
what he goes yeah i was trying to come
right as i pulled the parachute and and
and i had to watch porn i go
and it's what i say all the time and
it's the it's our like loophole
it's for work but it was for work right
for guys like us that turned our hobbies
into our careers
it's like oh i'm gonna do the most
[ __ ] up [ __ ] that's not okay
but it's for work yeah right
legit it is the only time i watched porn
in in years
i mean no judging bro by the way i'm
just saying like and i'm also a drug
addict and i did the riding the bicycle
thing with the general anesthesia drug
yeah you know that's like taking drugs
for work that was even more scary that's
like david's saying like okay i'm gonna
start painting prostitutes that i [ __ ]
while i [ __ ] him
but but i did do that did you really
yeah there was so many things that i did
in my addiction that i didn't want to do
but content oh this is gonna be my book
later yeah wow like this is gonna this
is gonna be in the documentary it's
gonna be you know everything is going to
be a dope story for when i get to wild
ride one day you know with the blue
lighting in the back and so when i say
addicts don't give a [ __ ] i mean
they just want what they want they don't
think about like oh i'm going to kill
myself or i'm going to overdose they
don't think about how that's gonna
affect their family their families
families like all the people around them
it's just like this behavior is just
like a tornado just ripping through and
so
i'm like
oh i'm horny i wanna have sex right now
i'm gonna get a prostitute she comes
she's like a supermodel that's doing
this on the side i'm like oh she's not
like a sex traffic worker you know and
there's no consideration of her trauma
of where she's from how she and it's
just like i want what i want right now
and she's she's
she's selling her body and i'm willing
to buy it so we're adults and we're you
know it's all good so
i don't see the problem there you know
and that's just my life i was like
everyone's an adult everyone's making
their decisions good and bad and so
um when i say that broke me that's what
i'm talking about it just it just like i
i went to i i was doing an s program too
and uh when i went through my inventory
yeah my sponsor at the time owned a uh a
woman's battered shelter
and so i i went there and like you know
i put in hours you know yeah for each
number on the list that i couldn't make
amends to or whatever and i was there
for a while and uh you know
finally got to know some of the girls
and they were like you know what are you
what are you doing here and they all
crowded around and i was like you know
i'm making amends for like i was an
[ __ ] to women and this and that
that [ __ ] me up because that's like me
as i'm telling them why i'm there
there's like little girls around them
and i'm just like looking at all these
girls like dude like [ __ ] yeah it was
heavy but this is how change happens
right yeah so
so
so yeah my final
my final
area my problem area is work and food
like and so
i'm sitting at the doctor's office going
in my entitlement issues that's my
character defect right i'm like i'm rich
i should i do all these good things for
people and a lot of things that people
don't know about and i'm this good dude
that's just like helping
people so
i should eat whatever the [ __ ] i want
and if i want to get healthy i should do
the michael jackson [ __ ] and just like
hyperv you know the chamber and all you
know and i sit there and i go
no i'm not going to do this [ __ ] like it
feels very addict-y i feels like
if the stem cell thing goes well that
i'll keep coming back and i'll basically
be living in colombia and getting it
shot up into every part of my body and
if there's the you know
um
so so i said no
for now i walked out of there and then i
went into sad guy victim mode of like
you know i'm just like just be the fat
guy people like you better when you're
fatter like you're you're you know i
mean you're giving yourself a pretty
hard time you're not all right
you know i wish like all right so then i
so then i go on this is all happening
around the same time then i go on rich
roll and then he like i said he didn't
say [ __ ] i shamed i gave myself the hard
time i'm like
this [ __ ] because i'm reading
just his first chapter and he's like i
couldn't walk up the steps like you know
i was like
you know very similar like i'm in my 40s
and like i have everything to live for
and yet i can't even
so i sit there and i go [ __ ] man i can't
get my [ __ ] to like i can't and i know
that there's overeaters anonymous i know
there's food programs i could get
involved with so i decided to get
healthy for the best possible reason a
reality television show
so i get hit up
two weeks ago
two and a half weeks ago i get hit up
uh now let me see how true
no not for xfx and i'm trying to figure
out how most truthfully i could tell the
story without getting anyone in trouble
i'll try and i guess
let me ask you a question yeah um
because because so much of of what
you've been talking about it really
points to shame
absolutely yeah
with rich role you're like i gave myself
all this shame and you know like you
you seem to have a real knack for
beating yourself up and there's a saying
like if anybody else was
like treated me the way i treat me i'd
[ __ ] kill that person you know like
and and so my question is
do you think that
that it's actually
the motivation or the addiction is to
shame
oh [ __ ] yeah bro we like that [ __ ] right
because like
how did how did it feel being called
crackhead by conor mcgregor yeah as soon
as i saw it i was like stevo's loving
this [ __ ] i was like i was like there's
zero part of him that's offended by that
i absolutely absolutely loved it but
my example for that is like with food
yeah i would find myself
uh here after
a meal yeah as soon as i as soon as i
had swallowed my last bite all of a
sudden i want sugar so bad i'm turning
into a werewolf and i just wanted i want
the dessert and then i start negotiating
with myself and then
i think oh man i want dessert but i'm
gonna feel bad if i eat the dessert you
know like oh i should i shouldn't i
shouldn't do it i shouldn't do it and
then like i just somehow arrive at like
oh [ __ ] it i'm just gonna [ __ ] go for
it and then like the question becomes
this is a legitimate question
what was i actually
choosing was i choosing to have the
dessert or was i choosing to
have uh the beat myself up the shame
like is was that the reward right i was
seeking like yeah there's some kind of
[ __ ] perverse pleasure or reward in
in shame where that's actually why right
so people listening right now are like
i'm addicted to alcohol i'm addicted to
food i'm a dick you know whatever your
addiction is or whoever you love in your
life is addicted to something you're
like that's the problem
that magic spoon cereal
that that heroine or whatever
it's the trauma
like the shame right you're addicted to
the shame that's the codependence is the
root of it it's just the alcohol ends up
being the symptoms the dysfunctional
like self-medicating tool that you
choose to deal with the trauma that's
the whole inside that you can't fill
with any of that right so that's a
so that's it right and and that's why
people who aren't addicts
have such a hard time understanding
they're like
wait bro
you won a million dollars at the
blackjack table why are you still
playing like any normal people person
would walk up goes grab a party
but you want to sit there till you lose
10 million dollars and i'm like kind of
feels better
and they're like wait i don't i don't or
like
wait you had one drink and you're having
you got a good buzz going you're having
a good time you want to keep drinking
until you almost kill someone and like
are puking and everyone's laughing at
you and you're like yes yes like
so
in that way
and i swear i'm not trying to do this to
plug the tv show
i know that show is dope and for anyone
who hasn't seen the show show i'm like
that show's [ __ ] dope and i love it
and i'm so proud of like i don't have
shame about i have a lot of pride about
it and
it's just
not doing as well as i i thought and so
i go why is that
and as soon as the show hit
two of the biggest celebrities on the
planet like
i'm not gonna say their name but like
separately
contacted me through my my manager and
and
scarlett johansson
is brad pitt
tom cruise that level that level and
they're like
it is insane what you're doing about
awareness for addiction mental health um
you know just all this stuff and you're
talking so it's so brave and the whole
time in my head i'm like dude please be
on my show please be on my show and
they're just big upping me they're just
blowing smoke out they're like it's
[ __ ] like it it resonated i go you
won't be on the show and they're like
hell no i'm just calling you to let you
know i'm glad you're doing it i would
never be on your show and i'm like can
you plug it at least and they're like
hell no because that means what and it's
shame again like i have a friend who's a
very close friend of mine and he's like
i need to watch the cho show like it's
porn because every time my wife comes in
i close the laptop and she's like what
are you watching and he's like i don't
want to tell her because it's such a
hard show to watch with the topics you
talk about
because if i watch it with my wife we're
going to have to have a talk about
this stuff and i don't want to have that
talk
but on the flip side like there was an
episode where it was just all about
jerking off and how i can't stop jerking
off and how
it's like in our society we just turn
into a joke but it's a real problem and
and another friend of mine watched it
with his 16 year old son and because he
has the apps to monitor his his 16 year
old son who has a brand new cell phone
he's like
kid's jerking off like crazy like it's
like we watched it no he could he can
see on his phone what he's looking up
and it's just and he's like i have no
idea
no tools on how to have this
conversation with my son so i'm like
let's watch this show together they
watched an episode and then it's like
look stevo jerks off while jumping out
of planes dave jerks off like it's it
he's like it provided a space where i
can have that conversation with my son
but because of the
the nature of
so much of the things you talk about on
a show are shameful
it's causing shame in me to even talk
like the network called me they're like
bro
not one of your guests has plugged the
show on social media and why is that and
i'm like i don't know like
and and i and and you know so then i
start beating i'm like man the show must
suck but i know it doesn't suck i know
it's awesome and then it's like
well maybe
they don't they don't want to talk they
don't want to promote the things that
they talked about on there and you know
there was a you know a lot of episodes
that got pulled because the guests were
like i don't i'm not cool with that
being out there like wow yeah and so um
so shame is a powerful drug and i and i
could definitely get high off of it
so
and it's a
you know like i've had sponsors that
have been very loving and kind and
they're like let's go through the steps
you know and i'm like
you know i kind of i kind of like being
yelled at i kind of like the more
sergeant like hey we're doing this or
else you know because that ties into my
trauma of like neglect and abandonment
you know like
which is
um
you know like how do you measure how do
you measure neglect you know
so yes i'm being i
i think
that's the the missing component with
most people when they're like i don't
because they're because
at the end of the day
they're using logic
right you're like wait does not compute
a plus b equals c like why it's like
you're using logic to talk about things
that are not logical
like why are you trying to
if i was in that situation i wouldn't
like
first of all
every [ __ ] billionaire i know is sick
they're not
they're they're mentally not a normal
person stops at a million
a normal person goes i made 200 million
dollars this year that's enough
to make a billion dollars there's some
[ __ ] going on yeah so when you go when i
would have no you would never get a
billion dollars unless you were sick
like that you got to be [ __ ] up to
make a billion dollars wow you know like
i i saw that there was like a survey of
uh people
who
like about financial security yeah and
the more money people have the less
financially secure they feel like it was
like reported that people with over 10
million dollars of net worth
felt like
way more anxious about financial
insecurity than like people
like with like whatever i just i i
i don't want to say everything i said on
the ritual podcast but
talking about it there
reminded me of something while i was
walking to here is
um in 1994
uh a band called corn put out a song
called
spelled f-a-g-e-t and it wasn't about
like calling people it was
jonathan davis the singer of that band
that's what people were calling him and
i was 15 at the time when that song came
out
and um
i remember the songs it was it was that
song and there's another song on korn's
uh self
it was their first album was called corn
uh daddy it was like a 14 minute song at
the end where he's just crying and just
never heard anything like that
and
um in the trifecta of grunge music
nirvana pearl jam sound garden being the
the third stepchild there's a song
called slaves and bulldozers where
chris cornell hits every octave
now i know why you've been shaking and
it's like
all like in hindsight now looking back
at like all my heroes like every single
musician athlete that i look up to has
been sexually molested all my favorite
singers are sexually molested all my
favorite athletes are sexually molested
and
but i didn't know that at 15 and at 15
was right when i was getting into
graffiti
and
that movie pump up the volume just came
out with a christian slater and that's
the first time i heard the word
cockering
so i went to um
right here where trejo's tacos or
trejo's donuts is on santa monica was a
sex shop and that's where i shoplifted
my first [ __ ] ring
and uh sorry i'm all over the place my
dad
the only sex talk he ever had with me
this is the only thing like in that and
i went to jail for shoplifting and
graffiti when i was 15 also is when he
was driving me to do um juvenile
alternative work service cleaning [ __ ]
up on the freeway he was like
he found my porn stash
you know it was a television were you
holding it for someone else that's what
i told him
did you ever say that oh yeah that's
like a for you know yeah it's not my
i remember i was like it's john lee's
and eddie's like the like i didn't even
come up with the name of his or her
start up holding it from my friend well
no
my my friend i don't know my brother was
working at big brother so all the
hustlers were stashed in my oh yeah it
was like
are you actually we're holding
i was holding it no i don't know i mean
they're just piled in my room i had like
500 because he worked at hustler yeah
and so
i had this porn stash which was a
telephone book
because that's and then
in like i glued on the inside of each
telephone book with a glue stick like a
page out of victoria's secret or
something i saw on some mac it wasn't
like i didn't have access to like big
brother and that stuff yet but later on
i got some good stories for that and
then i would put that telephone book
with another
normal telephone book and i would like
hide it like i hid it well but because i
just got arrested part of the probation
officer was like go through the room
like see if they have drugs weapons so
he found it and so while he was driving
me back from like picking trash off the
freeway he's like
you know
you know me and your mother we're
christians so we can't have stuff like
this in the house
and
i was like oh that's that's john lee's
he came over and like and he's like yeah
well whoever it is it's it's gone
and he and then he like
pauses for a second and says you know
i was young too you know and it's just
normal to have boners and i'm like oh
god please
and he goes you know
i'll tell you what my teacher told me
when i when i was hitting puberty in
korea he's like take a cold shower
because
a boner is blood it's a lot of blood to
your penis and i'm just like [ __ ] dude
stop talking to me and he goes and just
run your boner away just go outside and
just run and then that blood will
redistribute as you're running and so
that was the first and only talk i've
ever had with my dad about sex and you
know within that you know i never
stopped crying by the way because of
like i was you know until i was like 27.
so i go and i shoplift this [ __ ] ring
and
basically this was my uh like i'm
realizing it now as i'm saying it out
loud it was a ritual
i'd steal spray paint because i couldn't
afford it
i'd get like
i get like as jacked up as i can
you know like that that boner you have
when you're a teenager when you can like
hammer nails with it and then i put a
[ __ ] ring around it so i could just be
hard the whole time like literally
and then i would
start punching my face while listening
to
screaming at myself you are
and like blood would be like dripping on
my shirt and on my dick and
um listening to slaves and bulldozers um
sound garden like corn and i would just
almost
i guess i was getting high i was putting
myself into like a shame like you're a
piece of [ __ ] you're nothing and
no one can touch you no one can do
anything to you because now you've just
hyped yourself up by listening to new
metal you've hyped yourself up by like
like literally getting the blood going
out of your face you're literally hard
down here and then i would just go out
and in the same way stevo is a very
typical
korean name david cho is the same thing
as being named john smith and i would go
out and tag david cho
like i didn't have a cool gang i didn't
and i would just write my name all over
the city i'd draw this like stupid whale
and i would just
be
so happy i was like i am breaking the
law i'm vandalizing i'm stealing the
tools to vandalize with no one can beat
me up because i just beat myself up no
one can call me anything because i just
called myself that and it was the
happiest i ever was because i had
nothing i didn't have a dime to my name
i didn't have anything and
so when you and i'm sorry i'm like all
over the place but when you say
people get less financially or like
secure as they get more money that did
happen to me because
it's like
even doing a show like
on tv is
wait a second you want to hear something
that [ __ ] me up yeah uh this saying
um
a poor man
only has to worry about his next meal
but a rich man
has to worry about his last meal
um interesting yeah
yeah that's super fun
if your next meal is all covered yeah
and then we're like hey dude you get
dark when you when you're yeah it's not
being in the present yes of course it's
future tripping
and and yeah so it's like [ __ ] man when
i don't have anything i just do whatever
i want i [ __ ] hitchhike i do this and
that and then
wait
the financial security and freedom that
should be coming from being
filthy [ __ ] rich
is now i'm like a stressed induced [ __ ]
like right and like
i love fx like fx is [ __ ] awesome
they've created some of the best tv
shows i've ever watched the shield sons
of anarchy all that stuff
but in the same way there's rules
to being on tv bad too huh yeah oh no
that's amc oh eric character but like
this sunday in philadelphia this is dope
stevo calls me i come we [ __ ] shoot
the [ __ ] in the car
and it's like and then you put it out
you know like when you do tv there's
rules there's regulations and it feels
weird to be like
i'm [ __ ] rich
i can make machines that work me out
while i'm sleeping i can do you know
and and now there's someone telling me
oh you got to cut this scene or you
can't do this and it's like i'm not used
to hearing people say
say no to me so it's like
and and then it's like well
if i say the wrong thing and i get
cancelled and i get da da da and people
take things from me and that's all like
perception like
i i
and and that's that's kind of like the
life i live which is stress-free i
for the most part
you know i don't do podcasts i just
chill i like i paint with kids like i
spend time i you know you know i do all
this stuff and i don't like talking
about it because i don't want to be that
guy and my therapist said you know you
should kind of check yourself on that
because
you get kind of even like telling that
story like you get so hyped up when
you're like hey i need to [ __ ] beat
myself up and steal and do all this [ __ ]
and then like when you're like oh like
you're almost ashamed about the good
work you do like you don't want to talk
about it because then you're that guy
that's like hey you know
so anyways you're correct i get high off
shame i'm working on it
and um
and so
i'm sitting there two and a half weeks
ago and i'm like i'm not gonna get lose
all this weight with this machine that's
that
that i'm not going to pay for not with
the stem cell you know
still open i guess but you know i'm not
i didn't do that dive yet the jeff bezos
anti-aging paper all the [ __ ] dive
and kind of just settling until i'm a
[ __ ] fat guy and then i get hit up
all right i won't say that i guess i
could talk about it without saying so
it's a reality show in the vein of
and i love these shows competitive like
survival shows like survivor naked and
afraid
uh amazing race like i love those shows
like that's my that's i love that
so i just never thought i'd get hit up
to be on one of those shows
and they're like and it's filming in two
weeks
and i'm like wait a second wait a second
what the [ __ ] dude like
who who who dropped out and they're like
click they're like
got covered and i'm like oh okay so so i
i'm like i i know i'm not like an a-list
dude like so i'm like the literally the
last guy and i'm like if you're calling
me
that means you probably called stevo and
everyone
yeah
and the guy's like i'm not trying to be
like used car salesman but the offer is
out to 10 people so whoever gets back
first is and in my mind i'm like
but then again i think that the one i
got called about we we could talk about
it afterwards yeah i'll tell you after
but uh i think it would have already
happened for some reason i'm but i'm
betting it's probably
probably the same well we'll see but
it's a show to test like your limits and
there's a charitable component there's a
charitable component to it and so
and it's for network too it's network tv
so i'm like they can't go get more
populous than that right fx is it's a
major network i wonder what the
landscape of [ __ ] streaming and
everything you know like if networks are
even dead you know but so everyone that
i know
and this gets into some douchey talk but
all the showbiz people i know are like
networks are dead they're not dead but
they're on their way out certainly
they're trying to compete in hospice
well this is how i know of course was
commercials the last time i saw stevo
out in public in the wild was at the
conor mcgregor fight right and for me i
haven't been out forever and so
you know and it's like um
here's like it's such a strange like
microcosm of like how the universe and
and social behavior but we go to the
fight and here's like the vip section
for the super vips and the kind of vips
and billionaire row right bro yeah and
it's like
and you know i rolled in with sia who i
you know i think is the dude
she's the best
so
so you see all these celebrities that
you've seen on tv and you're all sitting
next to each other and like so you feel
like everyone kind of feels but it's
like first day of like kindergarten like
yeah it's like do i just hey you all
know each other but you don't you don't
know each other at all
and
i i'm with a group of people our age and
like younger kids
so
um
i think mel gibson was sitting next to
you right really
he was a rower to a in front so and i'm
sitting and i'm sitting adjacent right
and
the kids that i'm sitting with they're
like in their 20s and they're like who
is that like people are like some people
are booing him some people are waving
him because we were there early right
and um i was super psyched to see you
oh that was like to see you too yeah and
i was doing a selfie video like hey i'm
at the fight and then like
because i'm with some famous people i
see mel gibson like you know scanning my
area and like right when he made eye
contact with me i flicked him off and
but but i was filming it like i have a
video of it oh yeah and he saw it and he
saw it
and i'm like
felt horrible immediately after because
i'm like i'm like [ __ ] that racist you
know like and i don't know the guy right
yeah like he might be like an awesome
guy but just in my mind i got caught up
with like [ __ ] mel gibson and i and i
was filming myself and i did this and it
was right when we made eye contact and i
could see actually he was a little
bummed out and maybe i'm making that up
but i saw in his eyes
oh like a miniature death like like oh
wow i had a i had a weird encounter with
him that night oh you did i mean i'm not
even sure what it was i'm not even sure
what it was but uh
but i acknowledged him in some way and i
felt like oh like he wasn't stoked about
it you know oh
i don't know like i can't say it for
sure but it felt like kind of crappy
yeah i just wasn't happy to meet you or
something yeah there's something right
you're like hey what's up dude big fan
he's like ah cool yeah no stevo is like
the best that because everyone loves him
yeah and you could tell like you you
love fighting more than anybody and
i do enjoy watching and i and the thing
is i do too
but i feel shame about it because i'm
like why because i'm like because that's
like hurt because that fight
we talked about the dude that god
pummeled right he just
i forgot i should know his name all
right you mean the oh that was sugar
shawn o'malley fought oh the guy just
like
portugal guy right and to see it on tv
is one thing to be sitting there and
hearing the blood
and the guy won't go down and everyone's
on their feet screaming by the way
if you ever got into fighting i'm like
not to say that you were that guy you
have your super power is you're able to
disassociate to feel no pain
you would be you would be a great great
fighter
yeah laughed
again yeah knocked you unconscious it's
like when i saw dana white it would be
great to put on a fight between me and
justin bieber because justin bieber can
throw a punch and i can take a punch
so i feel immediately horrible i send
the video to my guy who uploads on my
social media i'm like hey throw this
video of me like flicking off mail gifts
and he's like is that really in line
with like your like who you are today
and i go
don't don't put it up
10 seconds later trump walks into the
building and i do it again
he sits there he's walking through his
entourage and i hang over and i go
like i wanted to get it like right in
his face
and then i go
also don't know the guy right like i i
hear of what he's done but like i don't
know that guy and i go i mean we know
enough about trump to but i felt bad i'm
like that that's the answer to flick
like
so anyways the point is
we're at these fights the kids they
don't know who jared leto is they don't
know who the [ __ ] mel gibson is yeah
then the nelk boys come in everybody's
going nuts everyone's going nuts and i'm
like i have no [ __ ] idea who is it
guys logan paul comes in with his
brother they go nuts it's like that's
who the celebrities are
like brad pitt is not a list anymore
right
you said something pretty interesting to
me when uh we had dinner recently you
were saying that uh
you know you've got this motivation to
be remembered forever and like you know
like dude it's not going to happen dude
like you're not even
like
a hundred years from now like it it's
not gonna it's like getting in a car and
getting an uber
and then like smells like teen spirit
comes on and the 25 year old kid
driving the car is like oh what is this
and i go you don't know [ __ ] nirvana
and i go oh yeah that's classic rock now
jay-z is old people music like
people that live their life for legacy
it's like bro it's a rap it's a rap dude
it's a [ __ ] rap like no one is going
to give a [ __ ] about you and like
there's so much [ __ ] they're so like
right and and and that's what people
want they want authenticity they want
these things and so for my ego
i go okay here's the usual suspects that
are going to be on this survival show
washed up actors a fat guy a black guy a
crazy woman like they got the whole
thing and i'm like so i'm i'm sure i'm
being could be cast as the crazy guy
and because the guy was desperate and
they're like trying to find the last guy
he told me who the other guests were and
all this other [ __ ] that he wasn't
supposed to and and so in my mind i go
oh he thinks i weigh 205 right now he
thinks i'm like out of shape i'm gonna
get [ __ ] jacked i'm gonna get ripped
i'm gonna come in prepared i'm gonna
have [ __ ] research on every single
one of these guests i'm gonna have a
sketchbook i'm gonna it's uh i'm gonna
have like drawings of them so i can like
manipulate them and then on the show
i'm gonna play the most empathetic
caring
basically me like who i am but then when
they do the camera self-confessional i'm
gonna be like
the heel the evil guy and i'm writing
all this [ __ ] and and and guys in my
recovery group and my therapist are like
you're in your addiction right now
of of being an attention [ __ ] of like
your ego like
and and i go no no i'm not because this
show is about charity and about help and
it's about being
it's trying to be a feel-good show right
right so i go in all the ways that i
feel like my show failed like it didn't
become like this big thing this is a
major network it's populist if they dumb
down my message to like
40 of what i say even that's enough you
know
and and so i just
in a very unhealthy way start working
out four hours a day i lost 15 pounds in
two weeks um
and and yeah i'm doing all that [ __ ] i'm
doing the cryotherapy the uv and all
this stuff and um
it's just like dude i gotta do it it's
like it's some of that messiah martyr
complex like i gotta go on this show i
gotta make it my show you're not gonna
do it i said no
and and about that i feel
mostly relief
um
and a tiny bit of sadness and regret you
know huh you want to be the heel for a
charity show
yeah
you didn't hear the shame part
like i it's like there's something very
satisfying about
people calling you a crackhead people
like people hating you like yeah and you
know that right yeah you go do something
and like people like and i'm sitting
here talking [ __ ] about my own show the
people who watch it love it dude they
[ __ ]
fall out i [ __ ] loved it but it's
like that's what i focus on the one
thing that they don't like and then
that's where my attention is because
that feels more it's like the comment
section of youtube you know sure right
but the shame addiction is like freeing
almost the way you're explaining it's
like everyone's fear is like that people
will hate you yeah you'll be this enemy
so like you you do it
or like
now you're free you know like now that
worst thing that can happen to you and
like i watched your show in a in a room
full of people
super uncomfortable why are you sitting
back there why am i back here yeah i
don't know this is just where my seat is
but is that is that are you i'm ashamed
of myself i put myself over here no i've
watched the show so many times i've like
do you ever sit up up here yeah i'm like
for zooms i'm sometimes here okay but
i'm not i'm never back there but you're
so handsome
thank you yeah but um but we watched
your show in a group people are super
uncomfortable but then we're like
we got to watch another one like the we
felt
yeah discomfort watching it but there's
also something really freeing and like
relieving about like okay like
the fear is like what if i have to sit
next to someone and feel uncomfortable
and like sit next to my girlfriend while
we watch this like think about jacking
off but like now we did it like i you
feel better you know it's kind of like
puts you through your worst fear and
maybe that's part of the shame addiction
it's like you're free after that because
the fear is shame you know yeah and and
like one of the episodes that got pulled
like i like i feel like you and me like
are very similar like we're very
comfortable
um
like being a victim or being like
like at like i'm i'll just speak for
myself i'm very comfortable when people
hate me like i'm like okay cool now i'm
in my comfort zone i don't i don't know
that i i can you're not that way i
didn't yeah
i totally don't want people to hate me
[Laughter]
but like
but like just like the conor mcgregor
thing like when he called you a croc
head on twitter like that was silly yeah
yeah i i can
he liked the attention
of course right and that's what i mean
when people hate me
they usually hate like when i'm paying
attention they're like and you were
on episode four you did this and and i'm
like you hate me so much yet you watched
everything i do you pay attention to my
career so it's like i know you're a fan
and you're just trying to get attention
in your way and me getting the shame of
you humiliating me or writing hurtful
things is also attention for me you know
so
um
yeah i i that's the thing that i
the show has been unbelievably received
by the people who watched it and loved
it and i can sit and i'm sitting here
focusing on like
oh well this guy didn't retweet it or
post it and like just like he said none
of your guests post about it on social
media and i was like [ __ ] but like i
it's not that i didn't want to promote
your show i just never promote anything
like i don't even promote my my phone
yeah
i just don't i go on a show i never
promoted no matter what it is pretty
much i i i was not calling you out in
any way
i didn't think that you were but uh but
um
[Music]
we certainly got the the you know the
chance to
s
yeah it's a really cool show i highly
recommend it honestly yeah
but that there is shame in
like to do a show like that and like i
can be proud like i am proud of the show
i put out and then to have
so many people like pat me on the back
and give me the atta boys and be like
bro like it's
it's such a brave thing and like all
that that gives me shame
right the good the good part is like ah
[ __ ] dude i'm not used to like i'm used
to doing something and then being
polarizing and half the people hate and
this and that
and uh
yeah like even
yeah that was i'm just thinking of how
we ended up having dinner at sia's house
because i went to the fights with sia
yeah and
we saw you
to um see this thing on sunday oh you're
going on sunday we're gonna come
all right i gotta i gotta i gotta get to
your place where i can just enjoy it
because i'm like
i'm i'm in this place where my life is
about helping people and in a way it
always has
and yet i just enjoy someone's like i
like it when the legs break i hear when
the uh when someone fights i i enjoy
like it's not a fight without the
knockout and something being
why don't we watch the fights together
oh my god
because i feel like that's what i'm
telling you like i feel like i it's like
eating like a cake that you shouldn't
eat when you're diabetic or something
but
people are like dude chill the [ __ ] out
and just watch did i tell you about when
i met neil donald walsh the
conversations with god author and i told
him i'm coming from yeah like i'm here
to hear you speak about spirituality and
i'm going to a ufc event like what's
wrong with me right is that wrong and he
said i wouldn't choose to go to a ufc
fight but but like i i encourage you to
enjoy yourself
right that's what he said are you
encouraging me to enjoy myself yeah if i
went to see a fight with you i would 100
enjoy myself and all this shame guilt
would go away yeah i'm not going to the
fights oh you're going to watch it
on tv oh [ __ ] i'll go watch it with you
cool man let's do it all right and we
don't need to to drag this on any longer
i think we we've done a a wonderful job
of owning [ __ ] once i i'm feeling i'm
feeling shame right now why why i i've
realized i used to have a podcast called
dvda say and
i'd go for four to six hours oh yeah and
than this oh really this is a long one
for us yeah oh [ __ ] i wish usually an
hour we you know i'm gonna be honest
like i i watch mostly the clips
so i didn't know how long they they go
like but the mark is generally one hour
oh okay
okay [ __ ] yeah give or take so i don't
podcast that much but when i used to was
four to six hours so when i go on ritual
or i go on bobby lee's and they go all
right i even though you're telling me
that most
my mind goes immediately too i'm not
being interested enough they're cutting
me off
this is a hundred percent way longer
than usual all right okay
all right yeah and dude you've been
fantastic i didn't even get into my
stevo stories but all right
again dude you've been fantastic
and i just think that you know i i'm the
same way
i'm the same way i'm meaner to me than
than anybody else
but uh like then
just [ __ ] give yourself a break over
here
and do a steve impression yeah
yeah dude i'm [ __ ] stephen i'm
[ __ ] so mean to myself
i [ __ ] shot goodfellas clothes at
target i [ __ ] eat all this magic
spoon i do cocaine with mike tyson
i [ __ ]
embarrass the wu-tang clan
thanks for losing my show wild ride i
don't promote [ __ ]
i care about the climate i care about
dogs i care about
the stimulus package in kovid but i
don't give a [ __ ] about myself i stick
shark food in my ass and i swim with
sharks
i [ __ ] jack off while i jump out of
airplanes and i light myself on fire
come check me out on tour steve-o wild
ride listen to the podcast [ __ ] yeah
yeah dude
that was great
yeah
i i love it man
thanks thank you thank you bro thank you
man
yeah dude doing that podcast with us
legitimately stressed david cho out
man
that i'm not happy that that's the case
but i am super honored that he did it
you know like what it would have broke
i've actually been seeing him
more regularly and uh
i'm just
considering him a friend which is um
crazy you know like i've got rich
friends
[Music]
thank you for sticking around and um
yeah dude life is good man super stoked
i finished that book i told you about it
it's so [ __ ] good
but yeah man
hustling man